las protestas de ambientalistas en hat
siguen su curso y la atención aumenta
este viernes al menos dos manifestantes
fueron arrestados mientras el gobierno
intenta desalojar a los activistas que
llegaron al pueblo para evitar la
explotación minera el ministro de
economía y acción climática alemán
referente del bloque de los verdes
criticó la resistencia civil
hay muchas buenas razones para
manifestarse a favor de una mayor
protección del clima Incluso en contra
de los verdes pero luxehat es
Sencillamente el símbolo equivocado los
manifestantes han acaparado el pueblo
abandonado a lucejal no solo en la
superficie sino también tomando pozos y
vías subterráneas
en las últimas horas sumaron un poderoso
apoyo mediático el del activista sueca
greta tambor quien llegó al pueblo para
adherirse a la protesta
creo que es absurdamente absurdo que
esto esté sucediendo en el año 2023 las
personas más efectivas son claras la
ciencia es Clara necesitamos mantener el
carbono bajo tierra y esto es Alemania
es realmente vergonzoso ahora mismo
deberían de tener esta destrucción de
inmediato y también asegurar una
transición justa y Justicia climática
para todos esto es solo una parte de
movimiento climático global y nos
mantenemos Unidos en Solidaridad esta
situación sucede en un momento donde
Alemania Busca soluciones para enfrentar
la crisis energética buscando Fuentes
diversas como la extensión del
funcionamiento de plantas de Carbón que
se esperaba dejaron de operar hace